Continue working on your project or open the file named 5-Vegetation, if you need to catch up.
Twinmotion offers many vegetation assets and different ways to apply them to the scene.
As always, and to keep scene management in check, create a new vegetation container and make it active.
Let's start with trees. In their simplest form, they can be added to a scene much like any other asset with a simple click and drag from the Asset Library.
Once a tree is added, you can control its age, which has a direct influence on its size, its growth, color tints and whether it's affected by wind and seasons.
If you were to revisit the Ambience panel and change seasons, you'll notice how the leaves change colors or even disappear in winter.
However, this technique of planting trees one by one is fine when you have just a few, but if you need many it's not very efficient.
Instead, you can use one of the scatter methods at your disposal.
Using Populate in the dock, expand the Foliage panel. Choose the Paint method.
From the Asset Library, drop a few trees in the panel by choosing the tree types you want to scatter.
Select the trees you want to scatter about in the panel and then choose the Paint icon.
Paint an area to plant multiple trees.
The advantage of this method is that the painted trees are recognized as one entity by the engine, which improves performance.
Another method of adding vegetation is to use the Scatter tool. We'll use it to add grass in front of the building.
Currently, we only have a bitmap applied to the grass areas and a bitmap can only do so much.
If we get close to that area, the effect is quite poor.
And so, we'll use the Vegetation Scatter tool, which is more suitable for grass than the Paint tool, especially on bound area.
As with the Paint tool, we are asked to add models to scatter.
We'll use Long Grass 1, 2 and 3 for now.
Select all the thumbnails and then click the Scatter Add tool.
Click the grass area in the viewport. Grass is scattered about. With every additional click, you add to the density.
I'll go with a total of 3 or maybe 4 clicks for now.
You can exit the Scatter command with a right click, but still bring about changes to what you did.
For example, all three grass types have been scattered with default options.
You can select one or more and adjust their settings, such as Size, Color Tint, Dryness and more.
You can also decide to add another type after the fact, and scatter that one a bit more.
An Eraser tool lets you remove any excess around the boundary areas.
I will stop here, but feel free to experiment a bit more with these tools.
You can also check out the final file named 06-Final if you want to get a few more ideas.
Keep in mind that a few containers have been turned off in the final file to increase performance.
You just need to enable them again to view the full scene.
This marks the end of the Twinmotion Part 1 class, the Basics.
Once you are comfortable with the tools you learned about here, then you can learn about the next steps in Part 2, where you work with additional tools.
You'll learn about man-made lights to create night scenarios, as well as media output to save still images and animation videos to disk,
as well as producing a self-executable project that you can share with people who do not have Twinmotion installed.